back up sweet this is a nice tv
i know
citizens of the reject nation going to
watch the movie black phone today and
i'm joined by the lovely and talented
roxy the
strider i love it though am i more
lovely or more talented this is a
terrible first impression uh you are
more uh talented i'd say yeah i was
listening to uh
one of your videos with harloff i think
he mentioned the black phone and you
said you hadn't seen it and i've been
wanting to watch this movie myself so i
was like this is perfect i feel like
it's right up my alley i hear that i'm
going to love it so i'm going to be
really disappointed if i don't wow and i
knew if you watch roxy you'll see she's
a very very honest individual so she
doesn't like this she's going to let you
guys know you go follow rocks on social
media world girls channel as well where
she's teamed up with two other lovely
talented women who aren't getting
invited here oh
the shades yeah starting drama today
please don't show them this video i i am
not good with confrontation um but yeah
if you guys can leave a like that would
be amazing subscribe click that
notification bell get notified we got
another movie reaction up have you seen
scott derrickson's other movies like
sinister or no name another one doctor
strange the first one yeah do you know
how much i don't like doctor strange
they're off to a great start
[Music]
[Applause]
there were asian kids in the 70s in
colorado
we don't know they might get taken
[Applause]
[Music]
oh man she's watching you
staring at us
[Applause]
you deserve to get kidnapped
no
this does have a very authentic 70s vibe
to it you can tell the audio at the
beginning too it's like horror audio
yeah yeah
your arm is mint
you almost had
good game mint in the 70s
[Music]
dude this guy's having the time of his
life right now
until
i knew it
i feel bad for joking about it
oh creepy it's the 70s so it's grainy
i think in like
70s 80s that's when there were a lot of
missing children and like the rise of
serial killers and [ __ ] the milk cartons
yeah exactly
well he's an abusive father you can just
tell
mr yamada's putting them up again you
don't think they're gonna find them too
not how they want to
come on let's go we're gonna be late
i really love the way this is shot yeah
it looks awesome
like a nail you scrawny little [ __ ]
then do it
[Music]
unless you're scared
oh holy crap
what the [ __ ]
[Applause]
oh my goodness
[Applause]
oh my god oh my god this is really
violent feels very real coming out queen
not fooling anyone annoyed
jesus is everyone here a bully what you
doing in our bathroom
huh
see the sign
it says boys yeah boys
[ __ ] move
hey finn
what's happening
you know just
keeping on keeping on i guess
[Laughter]
cool there
who's
yes
i was so that guy when i was his age
which one
you know that one yeah yeah yeah
you're gonna have to stand up for
yourself one of these days
i don't know
i got cheech and chong shirt you got
time to stop by my house after school is
it math again mr johnson talks too fast
he doesn't explain it right not like you
can you walk me through it if i get
another f i'm suspended yeah sure
i like them together friendship goals
i had a dream about it he was taken
that's all by man with black balloons in
a van we found two black balloons at the
scene gwen and we never release those
details either there's a leak in the
department or what i'm the grabber no
vance got held back twice i've seen him
fight and trust me he could kick the
[ __ ] out of either of you blindfolded
when watch your language yeah i took him
down cause obviously i'm the grabber you
dumb [ __ ] fart knocker
i love her
what aren't you telling us
that sometimes my dreams are right
oh interesting is she like a pr
premonition yeah power
okay or maybe she saw it
yeah it's probably
this pen's making a lot of appearances
oh no
oh
what the hell no
hit me again and i'm dropping it
you drop that and then we'll breathe
your ass towards this heart
oh my god
no no no no god damn
you are not your mother
that means you do not hear things
they're not there you do not see things
that are not there okay they're not
there granny jesus oh my dreams are just
say it again
my dreams are just dreams
oh [ __ ]
this who's this little girl she's
amazing she is
okay
this feels very much like a stephen king
movie i have like such a so much harsher
than i thought
i love siblings though it's like that
and that moment where she needs that she
need her brother
not him
he didn't even say it
what
oh man
he was like the badass warrior one and
now they're gonna kick the crap out of
the kid
do you know kitten and robin
ariana why were they walking towards
each other like that though
i know you think these kids would like
hear enough signs like maybe don't walk
that way yeah
i feel nauseous right now you could help
me have a dream or two and just see
something that could help the police or
me or anyone find him
i would follow you forever
no no no
no no no
no amen
get that button in there
no playing after live sound
sorry daddy
go to sleep
i love you
you don't
it does feel like a very realistic
portrayal of an alcoholic father
no i knew it i told you no
no
no oh my god [ __ ] cowards
oh [ __ ]
two of
oh my god
that is
he kicked her head
the bullying is so relentless in this
movie
where are you going
i'm staying over at susie's tonight it's
friday so i'll look after dad see you
kid
she is
great both of them are
[Music]
oh
you see that
yeah
would you hand me my hat
do not
throw it throw it throw it throw it oh
my god you know this guy's
would you like to see a magic trick no
yeah are those black balloons in there
oh my god
stop
this
oh my god
[Music]
this is so much harsher than i thought
it was gonna be
i should snap your neck for what you did
to my arm
oh what he did to his oh it was his
heart but that was that
oh my god i was like damn dude dude what
was it the pen that he did in his mind
yeah i think he's a rocket pen
you don't have to be scared
nothing bad
is going to happen here
i'm going to go get you a soda
and then
earphone ring
the black phone
do you know who that actor is ethan hawk
that's ethan hawk
i didn't know ethanol was in this movie
i think
i think no it sounds like him that makes
sense they worked on sinister yeah okay
that makes sense hi daddy
no i haven't not since school
[Music]
no
night
night time
he's already got someone oh i have
goosebumps
if you try to touch me i'll scratch your
face
and whoever's coming will see and ask
why
this face
hang up the phone now
he is creepy man yeah
i don't think i ever even saw a trailer
for this
oh
it's like you can't there's no moment to
breathe
[Music]
no it's the call to black phone try to
use the phone
i'm not getting anything that's not true
honey
pick up every time you don't know
stop it
stop working
oh oh my god i can't bring you anything
to eat
if you weren't gonna feed me why'd you
even come down here
i just wanted to look at you
okay
it maybe it's like split
multiple personalities maybe i'm trying
to figure out what the
what the ritual is that he has here that
was different hair too he's like it
wasn't me yeah
hello
[Applause]
did you catch what he said no did you no
i don't remember my name
why not
it's the first thing you lose
first thing you lose win
oh
we met once
[Applause]
your arm is mint
you almost had me oh [ __ ] it's the asian
kid dig down underneath the foundation i
tried but it wasn't time for me to take
up and out the other side
hello
[Music]
oh no is he losing his memories
[Music]
oh interesting
that's gonna get backed up real quick
yeah man
you think bruce is alive or dead
i think he's definitely dead he's gotta
be a ghost
breakfast
what did you put in that huh eat it
don't eat it
you're already down here
what do i need to drug you for
those eggs look good
did you not lock the door
no no no no no don't open that i mean
dude but don't i don't know
i think
don't miss the phone call
no no don't go upstairs no
why not
it's a trap
fat
fascinating it's a homie
oh [ __ ] this is [ __ ]
that really got me
do
not
go
upstairs
what is he doing well i got nipple
chills he's waiting
on the other side with that [ __ ] belt
he'll beat you with that belt you pass
out
you beg him to stop
we all did
but he just keeps beating you
so he can talk to dead people and the
sister can see [ __ ] yeah she could
probably connect to the dead in
somewhere
oh dude
you're going to go up when they said not
to go up
on crack
kid
listen to me
ah
at least eat the eggs no
no
get downstairs get downstairs get
downstairs
oh this must be what she saw
when he was banging at the
at the door
no that is messed up
can he see him right now
uh his eyes are open i think yeah but i
don't know if he went high enough up oh
that's what you mean
see the walls separated from the floor
to our long cable loose from down there
ah
well pull it down
or at least be able to reach there
with the cable
[Music]
what do you see
the paper boy yeah so she can connect to
the dead
that's smart
no no no no
what's on his hand
no
oh
what you think
oh that's so smart how did it just like
magically
no he put it through yeah i know but
it's a strong it's a cable it's a little
more firm
no no no he's coming downstairs no no no
no no
[Laughter]
he's coming right now okay
oh smart yeah but then what
when he climbs up the wall
the guy's coming downstairs he's coming
downstairs he's coming downstairs he's
coming downstairs he's coming downstairs
he's coming downstairs
no no no get your fingers away
stop
no
no
oh [ __ ]
oh that is too much noise
it's soundproofed
your mother she just
became so convinced that her dreams
meant something and eventually they told
her to do things until she took her own
life so she can get in too deep
i don't want that future for you
sweetheart
but
what if it could help me find benny
mm-hmm
oh wow
that is unexpected yes doom graffiti uh
you're right for the missing kids yes
sir and if there's anything else i don't
know
come inside
come on samson stop it
all right let's show you something
yes right over here
oh my god he has to be able to grab
these kids and get them back to his
place very quickly which means he's got
a house with a garage how long have you
lived in the area max oh i'm just
crashing here this is my brother's place
i've been reading about this case a lot
and i'm in between jobs right now and
you guys could really use my help i want
to tidy up before your brother gets home
there's something to the brother
situation
is that below him
i can't tell if it's just a transitional
shot
he said he's his brothers though
tell me your name what do you care
i usually don't i find out eventually in
the paper they always print a nice big
photo
what's different this time
oh
duh
dog
you can blindfold me drop me off on the
street i'll walk home well tell me your
name
taylor mullen
it's a lie
paper has been friends oh he already
knew yeah i was really starting to like
you
finney
see is it vinnie or finney what's going
on with the window thing that he pulled
down ah good question is his name vinnie
or finney it's an inconsequential detail
at the moment
[Music]
oh so homeboy just kind of stays here
and just waits all night
what's he doing right now
i think he's trying to stay awake
[Music]
how come last time he looked ripped i
know it's exciting
i'm not trying to shame anybody but no i
was like you looked like super like yeah
that's exactly what i was thinking
is it two different people
the mask is it two parts and sometimes
he doesn't like yeah where the top house
yeah yeah
what's that about
it's an insequential dude no no actually
no i think it's important because with
the identifying as different
personalities
yeah you're thinking inconsequential
real thinking
what is it what is it what is it right
now but the sound got me oh my god it's
a hanging body
it's fresh
why is it oh those are kids you don't
have much time
the grabber hasn't been sleeping
he thinks this might be it that
he's gonna figure it out
who's gonna figure it out
his brother upstairs
though it is upstairs holy [ __ ]
if you don't play naughty boy
the grabber can't beat you but naughty
boy if he can't beat you
you can't move on to the next part
you're the next part of naughty boy
this is favorite part he's not trying to
escape yeah
what's the next part
you don't have much time he's not been
sleeping you said that too
yeah
he is now in his chair oh oh my god
the door is still unlocked
there's a combination lock
it was my bike lock he took it
when he took me what's the combination
oh yeah
i remember being afraid to forget it
that's why i wrote it down
what
where stop talking to the law man with a
bottle cap in the wall which wall
which wall the one on your right
about shoulder height when you're
sitting down
he's gonna play a naughty boy though if
he tries to escape remember when ethan
hawk said he had a visitor earlier on oh
yeah yeah
two three three one something two three
four one second
and you'll have to be very quiet about
it
or just stay down there i'm wondering if
the brother is like a filmmaker mislead
like that actually is ethan hawk's
character but they just cast someone
else's personality yeah like the brother
is one person like split kind of thing
yeah i know that's what i was thinking
before but it is weird that's different
person
but how far they're upstairs could he be
true true
it is shot so dark at times
he just told you if you don't go
upstairs so then you're never naughty
boy
but he never escapes he has to take a
chance
[Music]
i almost just hit you
yeah
i would grab like a fork or a knife and
stab him
you would
especially when he's in fat mode
god damn man figure it out just sign
this quietly
don't be naughty boy don't be naughty
boy silent
no
so intense
[Music]
no no he's waking up he's waking up he's
waking up he's waking up sorry sorry
the dog the dog
[Music]
oh [ __ ] he got outside
no no
run
dude run into like a neighborhood
did he hit him
like a pig right here in the street the
brother right and strangle you with your
own intestine fascinating
[Laughter]
i would scream anyway
i would scream anyway
naughty boy i would have screamed while
i was running you get out of that house
you start screaming
samson was barking at something it's
nothing go back to bad max
what is the structural layout of their
house
three stories yeah what is going on
there
i ask you for help when you give me
these clues that don't mean anything
and now this morning you wake up without
any dream at all
seriously what the hell is wrong with
you i'm with you girl
maybe you're not even real
oh my god
now it's time for an existential crisis
they're too young for that
[ __ ] you
what do you mean they got you out man
you just you should have ran into a
neighborhood scream
do you even know who you are what the
[ __ ] kind of question is that
you're a fan's hopper you should scare
me
if you knew what you had coming you'd be
[ __ ] terrified today's the day
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
it's kind of like decker montgomery
stranger things that's exactly what i
was thinking
[Music]
[Laughter]
west side story
[Music]
jesus christ
what are these kids
why
seven seven four one like a satanist or
something what is this tower
these kids are awful i don't know i'm
like shaking my body right now
these kids are so awful
[Music]
oh
spotted
[Music]
i spotted what the camera's focusing on
right now
where's waldo
way
oh [ __ ] she's like traveling through
this
tell them oh damn i got nipple chills
man it's crazy look at that it's like
stood up here everywhere you even know
who you are what the [ __ ] kind of
question is that do you even know who
you are i'm finney blake hello nice to
[ __ ] meet you finney blake right here
this is it
this is it oh my gosh you could reach
him your fence hopper i remember you
you should scare me
there's an outlet in the [ __ ] across
from the john
break it to the wall about two feet
above the outlet
till you get to a panel with screws in
it get the panel off you're into the
freezer
and then out to the storage room
thank you
this isn't about you [ __ ]
what is going on
wait for his sister oh no no no no no no
no that was disgusting
he was drinking toilet water yeah
sorry sorry you do what you gotta do man
what
yeah
how did that work it's just the right
size
what's that what is that what is that
what is that food
oh yeah it's refrigerator remember yeah
yeah meat
it goes to
outside i don't think the fridge is on
the outside
who's gonna hear him he's gonna hear him
he's gonna i i don't know
i think you have left frame roxy
[Music]
you know same bro same
phone thingy yeah you gotta go pick up
you have no choice
get up get up kid finney vinny
[Laughter]
delayed reaction
hey finn
it's the homie
there it is we've been waiting for him
i'm with you i've been with you this
whole time
yes
a man never leaves a friend behind hmm
and i'm not going to leave you behind
we'll be together against you [ __ ] that
you ain't gonna go like i did you gotta
stand up to him you gotta feed him man
do you remember what i told you mm-hmm
bruce lee movies there's some dance to
stand up for myself exactly someday it's
today finn yep today is the day you stop
taking [ __ ] from anybody yup
not a fighter like you robin you
couldn't even take him
you've always been a fighter finn you
were always afraid to throw a punch but
you always knew how to take one
and you always caught back up stop
thumping you're getting out of here if
you can't do it for you
do it for me what does it matter because
i don't want to die for nothing mm-hmm i
would at least have died for a friend
and because i can't kill that iko deputy
you have to do it for me
yeah you are being a puta you're gonna
use a weapon
phone
fill the receiver with dirt
pack it in tight
give it some heft you raise the phone
take a fast step back step forward step
back and swing
god the black lighting
again you raise the phone take a fast
step back step forward step back
no no you messed it up
i still be able to talk with you
this was the last call finn
oh [ __ ]
what about the pen you're right yeah use
the pen well none of the other [ __ ]
worked i mean that's why he's got to
stand up yeah but like why do you have
to go through the refrigerator thing why
if they knew it didn't work then don't
tell them to [ __ ] dig through the
i'm just pissed
damn dead
kids please dear jesus please please i'm
sorry i said you weren't real please be
real please
you watched jewish roxy yeah yeah jesus
gonna pull through today
i like the name jewish rocks the jewish
rocks in the house
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
[Music]
you found it
this movie has such a great grip on
atmosphere man
what the [ __ ] detective right please
oh my god he's shopping
i don't think no i think he
actually has a brother he knows it's his
house he knows his house he knows
he knows he knows
did you hear me
i hear you
kind of looks like jim carrey yeah i was
thinking that
oh my god he really is putting it
together
oh [ __ ] i hope he doesn't mess him up
with the phone yeah
he's gonna mess up the wrong guy
no
way
i knew that he was hiding something from
me down here a holy married mother of
god
can you call my dad call my sister oh
listen don't worry he's not here he no
oh my god he's
no no you won't know the story about how
i found you man no no no no no no don't
worry about it
no bottom part for the first time look
what you made me
do you made me kill my brother
no
oh naughty boy
now i'm gonna have to put you with the
others
looks like you'll find those naughty
boys after all
open up i would use a knife
but
you
are special vinny
vinnie you're finna
oh that is cruel
all right
you gotta find the other doors
go go go
yeah it's gabrielle
it's the wrong house
no it's not no it's not
oh my god
oh my god this is
he's gonna kill him
this is for every single person that
ever bullied you you mother
you're gonna get the phone
in the middle of a choke what phone the
phone doesn't even exist anymore
you filled the phone with sand my dude
it is for you
welcome to the nightmare end of your
pathetic little life
i can't kill you
so finn is gonna do it for me finn's arm
is mint
oh [ __ ]
i did not see that coming dead or is he
not dead is he dead or is he not dead
we've got a basement
great he did all the hard work
interesting timing
oh we got a piece of meat for the dog
okay
i thought he scalped it oh it doesn't
that way so you can get the stairs
this is where he buries him
i think he kills them someplace else
what that's the hole for him that's the
hole for the kid
[Music]
[Applause]
they're gonna see her brother's not down
there
[Music]
across the street
across the street is she looking at him
yeah yeah
[Music]
oh
that touches my heart
that's so sweet
[Music]
[Music]
what a cathartic ass ending man
that's some crazy [ __ ]
[Music]
why was he burying them across the
street
[Music]
now beat your dad up
i'm so sorry
please forgive
me wow on an ending shot
the perpetrator known as the grabber
owned two homes
one where he kept the victims while
alive and a second empty home across the
street where he buried them postmortem
damn
i thought he would be bigger he's the
one who killed the girl
that's right you show respect
uh yeah you guys ain't bullying him
anymore
go kiss that girl
hi finney um
i'll be finn
it is finn okay
i did not know for sure until the very
last line that is actually the way they
ended on that for me
[Laughter]
the whole time like i think it's vinnie
the entire movie
great music too oh man that's an
experience
that movie was [ __ ] excellent
yeah
wow holy balls
holy balls holy balls dude
i don't think there's a post-credits
scene trying to remember all these names
memorized out of respect
yeah could those fallen that was really
really effing good
i'm sorry about your pillow
yeah you've gone down and destroyed that
thing
you almost tore the inside of the
cushions out on that all right let's
talk about it all righty
black phone well roxy what did you think
you gotta get stretching after that
workout you
honestly i feel like i just ran a
marathon like i was going 360 man that
was i thought incredible yeah it was
really solid but also i feel like you
set me up
what do you mean like i thought that i
was gonna come over and like have a nice
chill
moment and instead i haven't felt my
heart beat that hard in like a long time
it was that was tough i thought it was
great but tough i thought it was gonna
be more of like a slower psychological
drama
and i was like this [ __ ] is oppressive
and making me tense the entire time it
was a real like tense thriller well
because when it wasn't physically
violent it was emotionally damaging so
there was no breathing because it wasn't
like when we were cutting away to the
the sister that she wasn't [ __ ] and
then when we're cutting back to him
so there was no we weren't safe anywhere
no not for one second and i think that's
a big i love the arc of the character
though the main got finney finney we
nailed down that name every time you
were saying vinnie finney in my head i
was actually thinking come on roxy it's
vinnie
i was actually thinking that
i'm pretty positive at one point they do
call him vinnie and at one point they
call him finn i thought the dad called
him i thought like the dad called him
vinnie at one point i think maybe he
thought that was his name and that's the
true problem with fatherhood yeah that's
that's the lesson of the story learn
your goddamn kids names
but him learning this that the whole
solution
through it all just leads to such a
great catharsis when he does stand up to
ethan hawk uh the grabber which i did
not know that there was ethan that com
piece of information
i completely missed so i thought you
were testing me i thought that that was
a trivia moment you're like who plays
who plays this guy and i was like oh
come on pretty sure it wasn't my
attitude
when i asked you that
pretty sure i wasn't like that's how i
felt so rocks
voices cockside huh
if you understood east coast you would
get that that's everyone's attitude
i understand no so you know who plays
this dude or not you don't know no you
don't know i don't mean to challenge you
my bostonian friend he is
so good
so good and i can't believe his agent
let him do something where his face was
covered the whole time that's brilliant
i love that show i respect that choice
so much i mean it's got to be one of
those like favor asks too because he's
he's reuniting with the director of
sinister like you haven't seen sinister
right no
phenomenal that he it he ethan hawk is
incredible when are we talking about
most like a couple years ago
nah like i don't know i think maybe like
five years ago or something like that is
this is
the star of it he's the main star of it
and uh it was the same to writer and
director oh i missed that one yeah he's
he's great in that film and that was for
a lot of people they consider that
almost a semi like resurgence of ethan
hawk because of
how
graceful in that film he is so to see
him here to be playing the the main
baddie and also you know
he was just in moon night as the main
villain i feel like what he did here was
just exceptionally more creepy and
what's better sinister or this it just
has a movie oh it's so difficult to
compare the two but i'm asking you to
anyway yeah you're being a dick
shocker
yeah i
i guess i would i don't want to play
this game
i don't know
like it's my channel i don't have to
play by your being a naughty boy right
now
i don't like it i didn't i didn't love
the term naughty boy throughout the
entire thing i i couldn't help but kind
of giggle at it like the naughty boy
thing made it feel sexual well i think
that's i don't think that's the point
though is this was i don't think it's
supposed to be comedically sexual but i
think a big part of it is to have a bit
of uh like i don't think he you know
does anything sexual to the children
like directly but i feel like part of it
is a sort of lustful vibe what was what
is your interpretation of what was
happening when ethan hawke's character
continues to be like i'm not going to
hurt you i wouldn't do that i've never
hurt any of the boys that wasn't me that
took them like is he what's actually
going on there i mean to me it felt like
it was
he's trying to you know um
uh i forget what the term i'm trying to
look for is but it's it's sort of like
the
ring out that's what i was trying to
think yeah
no no ring out
that's
right
this video is
[Laughter]
right they're not real no uh what i
think he's
the
bring out i forgot my original
appointment i'm trying to make it i got
some focus to try to find the word you
think that he's trying to
the um
the
you know i totally had like a smart word
in my head i did and she got so caught
up in butts and butt that i completely
forgot what i was gonna say i feel like
he's either what was your question my
question is do we think that he is
multiple personality do we think that
he's lying to him like what he's trying
to do is he's trying to pull out like
kind of the
the perversion of of innocence in a way
like he
he plays on the innocent actually wants
them to do something bad and it's it is
like praying on the sin like he seems to
embody this sort of satanic like
mentality they have this
jesus symbolism in there so it's i think
it is about pulling out the sin in there
and punishing upon it at least that's a
part of my interpretation of it but i'm
just i agree with you there i just don't
know whether the movie was trying to say
to us this is this man has multiple
personalities who and this one with this
kind of mask believes that he doesn't
hurt people and he wasn't the one who
kidnapped those boys but when he's
wearing this mask he believes this or
whether they were just saying bad guys
are bad guys who lie and sometimes they
claim they didn't do something that they
did do right right you know what i mean
at all yeah you're just trying to you're
trying to say that
there's some version of him that maybe
doesn't think he actually did some of
this could be i didn't know if that's
what i was trying to say because he says
at one point i think very early on when
when when the main kid finney is
abducted he does say i didn't
i didn't hurt i didn't say you took
those other boys didn't you and he says
i didn't do that he denies it yeah
that's a good point actually so i'm just
like maybe some people just lie he could
have just been lying or there's a
version of it in which he doesn't
that that version of him that wears the
mask like that doesn't think that he
took the boy but full mask version of
him knows he took the boy
yeah whatever this greater entity is
that he
fancies himself to be it's kind of like
have you ever seen a hannibal or red
dragon that kind of serial killer motif
that there he is a greater being than
that so i feel like whatever
entity he feels he's embodying that is
the thing that is the the real pull
definitely i was getting
m night vibes from it for the like the
unbroken split that whole
with what was going on but i hear you it
wasn't as directly as a split
personality i think he believes that he
is something of a bit of a higher
calling of some sorts yeah i'm not i'm
not sure but whatever ethan hawk was
doing it seemed very purposeful the
entire time the brother felt like he was
in a different comedy though like the
brother was doing something
it wasn't bad it didn't take me out of
it but i was just like huh where where
are you at right now you coke you're a
little you're like a few years early to
be blowing lines as hard right now it
was like a real
left field funny thing to infuse
in the movie and then with the accident
yeah yeah and i wasn't even entirely
sure of the
purpose of inclusion including him
because they were saying the grabber
owned all this but i guess it might have
just been for the mislead for the plot
point element
yeah there did seem to be a couple on
i don't know if they're unnecessary
because maybe if i watch it again i
would figure out why it's necessary but
i don't know why we had to have two
houses and why the kids couldn't have
been buried underground where he was
because that's where their ghosts were
and i'm not sure why we needed the
brother to be in the brother's home but
the brother's not there and it kind of
made us question like how many layers of
the house maybe something to do with
like
the cleansing like this is pure here um
you know jesus yeah jesus [ __ ] you know
probably just like jesus saying in you
know that's what you got to do at the
end of the day just say jesus that's
what it was it was all christ allegories
the entire time that little girl man
yeah what is this actor saying we have
the imdb pulled up
madeline mcgraw you s where do you see
that top right oh the very top
friend there yeah first name very
beginning of this whole search uh
madeline mcgraw we don't look at it for
a second what was her the character's
name
i would have when yeah
yeah gwen man right gwen stacy man yeah
there you go that's the queen stacy
origin story and um
it was crazy that they decided to make
this gwen stacey's origin as well that
little girl
slaps because i think some of the kids
sort of felt like child actors you know
like actors playing kids
those two though felt especially her
even though it's a supernatural power
that she has she felt like a real child
and they felt like siblings too like
that sibling connection i just think it
i i have a
brother as do you i think that like bond
i'm a younger sister too yeah so you
know the the boy girl sibling bond too
oh my brother's older there's something
about that older brother little sister
vibe that they the dynamic that they
showed where i was just like yeah that's
what it's like when you go when it's you
guys against the world it kind of feels
like that and i loved watching the
depiction of that because they just
genuinely felt like siblings that
had that like espn
espn they had that espn cnbc
[Laughter]
ah that's like that esp
brother sister thing
don't do it man
go away stay in the video
go away
yes yeah no more i've said stupider
things there all the time um
yeah no i think that which especially
when she is having more of those like
breakdown moments with her father i
think what they this movie did
surprisingly well for me
was
find a a rare gray
like the dad's awful he's [ __ ] awful
but they've managed to find a a gray
area for where the kids can have that
that
understanding towards an abusive father
like know that he's abusive know that
he's awful but also the movie shows the
pitiful side of him and shows you when
he is
like uh truly weak and then he's just a
hurt man and he takes it out on them so
it's not that i'm sympathetic for the
dad it's that i can see why the kids
find that complexity where they don't
just like you know
want to ditch him or they they do feel
that push and pull as well like it's
very real for a domestically violent
home of how they flash that out you know
that part does pose some issues as well
though because of course they have no
other option their mom killed herself so
they have no other parent that they can
go to and it is kind of that
uncomfortable moment as an audience
member at the end when
the boy is saved and the the son and the
daughter are sitting there and the dad
comes over to them and you're just
thinking to yourself this is what
they're going back to
this man who kicks the living [ __ ] out
of them like i get it's better than
being in a basement but like that's what
life looks like but i think it's also
showing that finney every time i say his
name now i just want to laugh i think it
also shows that finney is no longer
going to take that [ __ ] anymore
and he can he can be the man of the
house now
maybe
that's pretty big the sequel will be he
just murders his dad and now they're on
the run
i kind of do feel like there is room for
more story here i don't think they could
do a sequel obviously because of the
ending but what did happen with the mom
what are those premonitions or
what happened with the children too the
dead children are they just like
tethered to the home or do they get an
opportunity to
move on
there's souls yeah
oh jesus
jesus we were talking about the matches
jesus went in there
he resurrected them
he just took the wheel and now we know
what happened yeah there's definitely
created a whole world
like this this little
not little movie but it was a pretty
short movie but there was so much going
on outside of our
main dude yeah
well i think with the main dude it's
it's a cool
i like the connection that by him
defeating the grabber
it is him taking care of like a lot of
different goals of
overcoming the the obstacle like he will
stand up to his dad needless to say i
feel like he will at least stand up to
his dad we don't know what the future
that will be and maybe there's i do like
the ambiguity of we don't really know
what's going to become of the
relationship with the dad but then also
the you know with the children at school
he gets the opportunity to sh he's
obviously going to get the girl and then
on top of that too those people aren't
going to bully him anymore this whole
image has changed and
it's
neat i thought i i personally thought it
was really neat how
this whole movie he's trying to
strategize and get help of how he's
going to like sneak out and escape from
here when it all came down to i just
need to stand up to this guy the way how
i've avoided standing up to everyone
else my whole life and that was the key
for them so it's i wasn't expecting such
a neat character arc to unfold from it
there's a really good point like it's
not about getting out the window it's
not about breaking through the
refrigerator it's not about getting out
the padlock quick enough it's about
defeating the demon inside
that's inside the house yeah i thought
that i i agree with you completely that
that was a really interesting message
and uh i would like to agree with you
about the dad thing that he's gonna
stand up to him but i don't know i if
you are an abusive parent and then your
kid gets kidnapped and then they
they come home and you're still abusive
how the hell with that i mean
that's how i feel
yeah no i mean in real life a dad would
have to like do like years of therapy
and [ __ ] and like really go to rehab
like there's there's a lot more it
wouldn't just be a simple i'm gonna stop
in like in in the reality of it that's
what i was saying it's ambiguous for it
i mean your path is definitely the more
realistic path yeah
realism
like movie magic movie healing movie
character arcs they live happily ever
after or something like that i'm like
pull these kids out of school for a day
homie i know just keep making her go to
school and all that yeah i also really
love the part though that when his homie
finally calls on the phone the guy who
was standing up for him all the time and
he says i don't want my death to go
without saving you or whatever it was
like you want to die for nothing die for
nothing yeah my words were better yeah
yeah they were definitely more efficient
and more compact i don't want my listen
here's the deal my dude i don't want my
death to go without saving you though
that's the truth i don't want to die for
nothing i thought that that was really
cool because as a
watching it i kept thinking like well
all these kids are already dead but it
did feel like at least they died for
something at least they they did help
him
to be able to live that made it feel a
little better yeah it's true that's very
true good point i i like uh
i like the children actors a lot they
all the dead kids i like the dead kids i
like dead kids it's just a great thought
i like all the the kids no no i'm gonna
let you sit in that one yeah not
agreeing
no come on don't leave me in the coo
come on yes and that's what that's what
improv is yeah who would yes give me a
location
yes and i also feel strongly about deaf
kids
in the bushes
underneath the stairwell with the wrench
actually you know if the kids were
discovered that might be how their souls
like the bodies were found that could be
how their souls actually escaped from
being
trapped in that location
what's your deal with the kids and the
souls you're thinking that they're no
they were definitely their souls were
like trapped there you you think that's
what was happening
a thousand percent even though they're
across the street
you get so caught up in the most
technical [ __ ]
because yo they're across the street
that's right it's like why were there
two houses
no their bodies died they they were
killed though in that house yeah
so their souls were trapped though
and but now they're not because their
bodies are across the street so their
body shifts or their soul i don't know
they were connecting through the phone
ah
now you're now your semantics are making
me
get caught up in the great part is this
movie was awesome but if i think too
much about the soul meets body
you're making your own rules
yeah cause that's not what this means
i'm sorry
all right this is just a little uh i'm i
thought it was whatever all right the
sequel will explain it oh what's it
gonna be called
blacker
pack the sand into the cell phone what
it doesn't even make sense i can't do
that back and step forward i'm still on
the cell phone thing
i still have wi-fi
why can't i just call someone and get me
out of here destroy the cell phone with
the dirt can't i just pin my location
get me out of here please
no that's not how it works i also think
the uh setting of the way they captured
this was cool because
it felt like it was shot on film instead
of digital yeah especially with the the
cool
flashbacks i guess i i want to call them
flashbacks but they're also the moments
that the sister is seeing so
the premonitions but they were
flashbacks yeah they were kind of
spliced together yeah whatever it was
that the the juxtaposition of that how
that was shot with how the rest of the
movie was shot was really cool yeah it
was excellent and even this the art this
the whole production design like it
the cars the clothes everything about it
just really felt felt very lived in
there was such a great atmosphere too to
every quality of this yeah so
surprisingly because this could have
been like a slow
almost boring drama but it or or
something that could have been
perceived that way because i personally
like i love that elevated horror type of
vibe and it it kind of has that good
blend of both where it's like an
entertaining horror film entertaining
horror thriller
backed with being a little much more
elevated than that and more character
driven than that so i thought it was
like a good blend i agree completely and
also i think that one of the a big
strength of this movie was the fact that
it was what did you tell me 95 minutes
i think it's like an hour i think the
total run time's like an hour 40 but
it's like 95 and without credits
so 95 so
no mommy being sexy
all right sorry
possibly 96.
i just don't want to lay it down here i
think that that was i i actually
couldn't have taken
even five more minutes more of abuse so
it especially
my heart was like she started doing
backflips
at one point i wanted to flip my whole
chair around and i was like i think he's
gonna kick me off
smash the camera
well
this thing's destroyed now my nails went
into it your arm destroyed almost tried
to rip out the hair on your yeah i was
like wow she's really this is really
going hard here yeah i'm a grabber
you're a violent human being roxy star
not after you watch this not
comparatively
true
not comparatively to actual murderers
you know what i'm not that violent if
you watch the phone you watch this movie
about this murder i'm less violent than
that i'm not that guy
that's hilarious adding it to my profile
we should end on that note
conversation right there
oh yeah that was uh that was a great
film really impressed with it shouts out
to oh my god and the last thing we got
to mention the sound design was so
immersive from the minute it started
like even you know you know it's a
horror movie when you put a cup down and
it's like
and you just every sound kind of puts
you on edge makes the hair stand up in
the back of your neck from the minute it
started i was like oh and it punches to
the face that was like
hammers into my little ear drums
i'm sorry
i was hammering your eardrum
like a little like a little man in there
it doesn't sound like good sound design
that sounds like a very awful sound
camera
sounds like someone was hammering my ear
drums
no one was hammering my ear saying a
little man inside my ear being like
creating like the perfect sound okay
kind of like um
like
dopey or somebody
yeah
one of them you're talking about the
dwarfs yeah they're not that tight i
don't know if we call them that anymore
so i said dopey specifically
you knocked it out of the park i like
the music too music great do you want to
take it away on that yeah the music was
ideal
uh there were some there were some
popular songs like someone was nailing
the music in my hair it's like sharp
needles
i loved it so much it felt like somebody
was getting a screwdriver
it was like kind of a drill into my like
a drill bit you know
yeah no it was interesting when it
started probably with its most popular
song that was in the whole movie i was
thinking like wow are they gonna go with
how much money do they spend on music
but then there was only a few song songs
in it which i thought was a strange
choice the bullying was a bit excessive
to me at times sometimes it was like i
got it you punched him six times did you
have to punch him 12.
but sometimes i was like maybe you did
the commit there's like this community
just seems like everyone's a goddamn
bully
totally i forgot at the beginning they
said that it was in denver and then at
the end when the denver police was like
this was in denver just thinking myself
this was a different place before
cannabis
they like that little moment when the
guy
she hits the guy with the with the brick
and then she gets kicked in the face and
then they're just both sitting next to
each other and both bleeding and they're
like
yeah this is life this is this is so
good for the fact that he was clearly
dead he was on his on his way to die
dude was gushing blood from his brain
yeah that like you got to get it this
you would have a concussion or you got
to get that checked out and sometimes
concussion he's gushing blood yeah no
it's that's like a
usually when you see that movie that
means the character's about to die i
think i turned to you and said is he
dead
is he one of the ghosts
maybe
maybe all right now we're really in
four more points later
all right guys well
follow roxy on the world girls channel
just crawling around chairs the whole
time
yeah you were about to morph into
something this was it's morphing time
this was your wolf manager
yeah this movie did sound good to me
um
yeah follow roxy uh subscribe click that
bell leave a like thank you guys for
being here we'll um
catch you guys
yeah what he said
[Music]